le regard des autres une autre sentence
pour les familles les proches de détenus
solidairirees rattachés à la maison
d'arrêt de bois d'Arc depuis plus d'une
dizaine d'années leur parle les écoute
également bonsoir Michel vet et bonsoir
à marie-élè Jacu également vous êtes
respectivement présidente et
vice-présidente de cette association
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment qu'on ne prête pas assez
attention justement à tous ses proches à
ses familles de détenus qui elles aussi
sont
victimes c'estd je crois que surtout le
milieu carcéral fait peur alors
évidemment une prison dans une commune
n'est pas toujours bien accepté
euh
l'engagement également des bénévoles
pour accueillir les familles n'est pas
toujours compris même même dans nos
propres familles dans notre propre
entourage ceci étant c'est indispensable
à mon avis quel est le sentiment
justement aujourd'hui de de ces familles
que vous rencontrez qui se se rendent au
parloir mais qui avant échange un petit
peu avec vous alors il a c'est
complètement différent vous avez les
familles qui arrivent et qui viennent
pour la première fois qui sont souvent
très intimidés qui ne se confient pas et
puis ensuite il y a une espèce de
régularité je dirais où chacun se
connaît on nous présente les familles on
nous présente les enfants chacun raconte
sa petite histoire mais je crois qu'au
début il faut que les familles
s'habituent à venir au parloir je pense
qu'il y a une grand intimité entre elles
également elle elle cède avec nous c'est
pareil je crois qu'elles aiment bien
c'est on essaie de faire un accueil
chaleureux Agréable pour elle du moins
c'est ce qu'elles nous disent maintenant
comment se passe justement l'accueil de
de ces personnes qui avant de rendre
visite à leurs proches qui sont détenus
à la maison d'arrêt alors déjà il y a il
y a une première une première
intervention c'està-dire que des
familles qui ne sont jamais venus pour
la première fois donc
entrent dans dans cette
dans cette salle d'accueil déjà pour
apporter la première fois du linge à un
détenu alors qu'elle n'ont pas encore de
permis puisqu'il faut un permis de
visite pour venir voir le détenu donc la
première fois est toujours très
angoissante hein c'est donc pour la
plupart pas pour tous pour la plupart
c'est la première fois qu'ils viennent
dans ce milieu carcéral et là c'est un
peu difficile quelquefois mais nous
sommes là nous pour justement atténuer
un petit peu les angoisses essayer de
leur expliquer essayer de de de les
informer de les écouter
euh et puis tout doucement
euh ça vient euh au niveau de de deune
espèce d'empathie enfin il faut ces
familles aussi ont un sentiment de de
culpabilité peut-être voir de honte on
dovent très souvent ces familles euh
sont sont rejeté
par le voisinage par quelquefois la
famille aussi et et elles viennent avec
beaucoup de de d'angoisse et là on
essaie de montrer que il y a pas de
différence et c'est ça qui est important
pour eux c'est que quand ils
arrivent ils s'aperçoivent que on n'est
pas là d'abord pour les juger c'est
d'ailleurs dans notre code de ou de
déontologie deontologie surtout pas
juger ses
familles et et puis essayer de
comprendre essayer de mais surtout
écouter à mon avis c'est une question
d'écoute et c'est l'action de solidaire
depuis plus d'une dizaine d'années le
lancement de l'association alors
l'association a été créé juste après
l'ouverture si je puis dire de la maison
d'arrêt qui s'est fait en 1980 et en
1900 dès cette ouverture de de la maison
d'arrêt il y a un certain nombre de d'
association enfin de personnes qui ont
créé un groupe pour savoir comment on
allait faire et comment on allait
obtenir de pouvoir accueillir les
familles et au
départ il y a il y avait pas du tout de
de structure d'accueil que ça soit dans
dans dans pratiquement toutes les
maisons d'arrêt ou les prisons c'est
venu
depuis pratiquement partout et il a
fallu que ces personnes qui se qui se
préoccupaient des famille
euh viennent avec une camionnette au
départ à la la sortie de la enfin à
l'entrée de la maison d'arrêt une
camionnette pour recevoir les familles
et au bout d'un moment évidemment ce
groupe a trouvé que c'était quand même
aujourd'hui les conditions d'accueil ont
changé alors nous avons pu obtenir enfin
je n'y étais pas à l'époque mais ils ont
pu obtenir une salle euh assez véus c
pas pas terrible au départ et puis tout
doucement ement avec la direction il y a
eu des transactions et nous avons pu
obtenir une salle beaucoup plus agréable
mais il a fallu quand même quelques
années avant que tout ça se soit on va
continuer à parler des actions que vous
menez on va continuer à parler de de
solidaire et principalement aussi des
bénévoles mais on va juste faire une
petite pause et écouter les les
cinquantinois les ivelinois nous sommes
allés leur demander quelles sont les
actions à mettre en place pour époler
les proches de détenus vos opinions vos
avis je pense que je pense que l'idéal
ça serait entre guillemets prioriser des
places d'embauche ou des contrats alors
attention parce que les
familles enfin c'est pas la faute des
familles si le détenu est en prison euh
rapprochement peut-être au niveau
logement ça peut être fait euh soutien
des autres donc il y a les
associations faciliter l'accès parce que
c'est pas toujours facile d'accéder à la
prison hein donc entre
autres
le linge et choses comme ça faciliter
l'accès peut-être leur apporter un
support extérieur à ces gens-là su
psychologique c'est essentiel et il faut
trouver les personnes compétentes pour
le
faire échanger discuter avec les proches
des détenu avec les familles c'est ce
que vous faites avec cette association
ça se déroule une fois par semaine non
ça se déroule euh bah nous nous sommes
présent à la maison d'arrêt par équipe
de deux ou trois euh chaque jour de la
semaine sauf le dimanche euh le lundi le
mercredi le vendredi et le samedi étant
pour les personnes qui qui viennent en
parloir et puis le mardi et le jeudi est
réservé aux familles qui viennent
apporter du linge parce que justement
elles n'ont pas le permis de visite qui
sont les bénévoles qui échangent
justement avec ses proches alors
nous c'est-à-dire que oui vous avez des
on est une petite quinzaine donc vous
avez des bénévoles qui échangent avec
les familles au moment des parloires et
vous avez des enfin des bénévoles qui
échangent au moment du ce qu'on appelle
nous le dépôt du linge alors le dépôt du
linge la différence bien sûr c'est que
ces familles n'ont absolument pas de
permis de visite donc elles viennent
souvent d'apprendre d'une manière
complètement inattendue B form alors
nous en tant que bénévole oui on onç une
petite formation pour pouvoir leur
indiquer exactement quelle démarche
faire pour obtenir le permis visite si
l'on est imprévenu si l'on est un
condamné c'est un petit peu différent
euh et elle-même on leur donne des
conseils comment apporter du linge
qu'est-ce qui est interdit qu'est-ce qui
est autorisé et cetera donc si vous
voulez on fait le lien entre
l'administration pénitentiaire les
surveillantes et puis euh et puis les
les les détenus donc et vous recherchez
actuellement des bénévoles intervenir
oui oui oui oui ça c'est oui nous
recherchons des bénévoles
essentiellement essentiellement pour le
le samedi matin qui enfin le samedi
parce que là on a un petit une carence
au niveau de qu'est-ce qui fait les
bénévoles c'est la peur du milieu
carcéral peut-être le fait de
s'approcher d'une prison de rentrer en
contact ave je pense que de toute façon
oui il y a toujours ce problème vous
savez quand disit tout à l'heure par
exemple dans votre entourage on n'a pas
forcément compris au début lorsque vous
vous êtes engagé absolument oui tout à
fait tout à fait et et je dois dire que
la prison estant vraiment sur bois d'Arc
sur la commune et que ça a été difficile
de faire admettre aux arc
cette prison cette maison d'arrêt euh
mais que maintenant bon on
est on va au forum par exemple on
participe au forum de boisarcy au forum
des associations et on sent quand même
qu'on est ass
accepté cecitant ceciétant les gens nous
disent ben c'est bien ce que vous faites
mais maintenant il faut maintenant voilà
il faut que les gens viennent vous voir
il y a un numéro de téléphone qui s'est
affiché à l'écran n'hésitez pas à
contacter l'association solidaire
justement si vous souhaitez être
bénévole merci à toutes les deux nous
allons fermer cette édition du 78 à
présent auparavant le traditionnel micro
trottoir avec les vœux pour 2013 que
vous souhaitez micro trottoir de la
rédaction qu'on voit l'aménagement de
Sky West qu'on attend depuis longtemps
une bonne année pour tout le monde et
puis bon en espérant que cette année
sera bonne avec du beau temps et bah une
économie un peu plus floriscente on va
dire ben la santé on commence saoir de
l'âge donc pour nous c'est la santé hein
et puis après B tu travailles alors je
souhaite une bonne et heureuse année à
toute la
population c'est la fin du 78 pour ce
mardi 15 janvier demain mercredi le
livre papier a-t-il encore un avenir la
question sera posé à Eric Ardin il est
libraire il est surtout ancien président
d'une commission pour le numérique pour
le Syndicat de la librairie française
excellente soirée sur TVfil 78 à demain
en direct DS
18h
[Musique]